so number one you can find stationary
points but they are not turning points
okay but actually this is wrong my Venn
diagram is wrong sorry I need to I need
to do this yeah really I should have to
put ten points for you but anyway oh
there are turning points these guys
there are not stationary points okay
that's the time to think about this and
I do need some more space here so I want
to draw for me she sets of axis two
separate ones
they can be pretty small this is still
an attending point so what i'm doing
here is number one i'm saying what
turning point are so change inside okay
I've just established you can have a
station report that is at the turning
point okay
but you can also have a turning point
that isn't a stationary point so here
are my two examples
okay um let's go with a familiar one
faster than a less familiar one y equals
the absolute value of X now what does
this look like you guys know exactly
where the most like right it's coming
down like so and then it bounces yes so
let's think about this okay
the greater over here is negative right
in fact this negative wasn't and then
after the origin it's positive okay so
the point 0 0 in this case it is a
turning point because the side to IDX
changes before and after okay all right
so it's a point at the origin okay
but your member uh I think we looked at
this same example we're thinking about
limits right at 0 0 what's the gradient
there gradient the gradient doesn't
exist remember we talked about
continuity and differentiability yes
continue differentiability the absolute
value next is not differentiable at the
origin because when you think about
what's the gradient approaching okay
over here as you get close to the origin
you're approaching minus 1 but if I go
to the origin from the top if you
approach it from Bob you're getting a
completely different value right so
there is no derivative at that point but
continue to change the sign another side
so therefore it says anymore and that
means you don't it turns all right now